40 people told me no so i had to take 60
meetings
to get 20 yeses the first question was
always what's the internet
and i had to walk through that
innovation is rewarded
making mistakes along the way does not
come with a big penalty
while that can be very very painful in
terms of your relationship with your
parents and your relationship with your
teachers
it's enormously useful in life want to
be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how
billionaires think and get some success
advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one go step by step
with jeff bezos so your question is you
know did i kind of anticipate what would
happen over the last 22 years
at amazon and the answer is god no so
you know amazon started as a very small
company
um it was me and a few other people i
was driving all the packages to the post
office myself in my 1987
chevy blazer and
uh when i raised money for amazon i had
to raise a million dollars
which i raised from 22 different
investors 50 000
each they got 20 of the company for
uh for the million dollars and
um it was a
40 people told me no so i had to take 60
meetings
to get 20 yeses the first question was
always what's the internet
and i had to walk through that and this
was 1994 early 95.
and so did i anticipate you know fast
forward to today and
the current version of it no it has been
one
foot in front of the other and i think
that that
is true for most businesses
where you kind of proceed adaptively
it's step by step
you figure it out you have a success and
then you kind of double down on that
success and you figure out what
what else you can do what customers want
rule number two
use all opportunities with bill gates
when i was young
i had to read the world book sort of
alphabetically
and it didn't have any videos you could
click on
and it was you know it's weird to learn
things alphabetically it's kind of hard
to create
quite the same framework as you can with
all these great online materials
uh and so i think the empowerment
now you know the opportunity to see
what's going on
whether it's in fields of science or in
places that are far away including
else most need it's never been so great
it's a wonderful time
to be a student now software in terms of
letting us simulate things
whether it's scientific phenomena or
social phenomena
it's getting better and better and so i
think
almost any major that you have nowadays
understanding you know what software how
it's going to change those activities
uh is a key part of of being at the
cutting edge
rule number three be innovative with
elon musk
first of all when we interview people we
we do ask
for some evidence of exceptional ability
which
in most cases includes innovation
uh this is not said everyone needs to be
innovative it's
but we certainly need those that are
doing advanced engineering
to be innovative and ideally everyone is
at least some to some degree innovative
so
at the interview point we
select for it for people who want to
create new technology and then the
incentive structure
is set up that such that
innovation is rewarded making mistakes
along the way does not come with a big
penalty
um and but but failure to
try to innovate at all comes with a big
penalty
you'll be fired okay yeah
all right the carrot and stick that's
the steak if you don't even try
um or or somebody doesn't even try to
invade or
their innovation aspirations are are
very are
not not very good then
yeah they will no longer be at the
company rule number four follow the wins
with grant cardone i don't think that
people burn out
i think it's impossible i'm not i'm not
a piece of wax i'm not a candle
so the burnout thing was put on us by
people that quit already yeah you're
gonna burn out dude you're gonna burn
out burnout is never about work nobody
burns out because they work too hard
oh you're burning the candle at both
ends i'm a spiritual being i create
energy this is a
irresponsibility like i've never met a
human being that was made of wax
you know oh yeah but you know burning at
both ends you're
you're a being you're a being okay like
quit saying something's happening to you
this goes back to cause and effect
i create energy and i love your example
of the kids
okay that kid can play that game it's
always a game though yeah oh die oh not
it's always a game there's nothing that
entertains people more than a game
and so when i was uh 18 years old man i
was playing a game called asteroids i
would play
i would play 80 of it today because it
cost a quarter every game right and i'm
just piling
throwing them in doing anything i can to
get quarters so i can dump them into
this
into this game and i was trying to get
to the next level look at how people
play candy crush
700 levels and they're still looking for
the next level over and over
it's games and that energy doesn't run
out until you hit
boredom because you can see a kid play a
game too long
and then they start getting like kind of
smashed in and their
attitude gets bad because they've been
playing that same game too long
yeah so i know that as long as i'm
interested
not for me not passionate for me
well for me for me i need to be able to
win at a game
if there's a chance i can win i'll be
excited about the game
if there's no chance to win i have no
interest
so for me for me the idea that i'm going
to follow my passions
is a little bit deluded for me
i i think people are looking for their
passion i would not follow my passion i
would
i would follow the wins right so are you
saying there's things that you can
really enjoy but you don't think you
could win is that what you mean i
i think if if yeah i think that if
you're
if there's no victory the passion is
is a little bit um
narcissistic like oh i'm gonna i'm meant
to be a
artist maybe ain't nobody buying your
art
nobody's buying it all you're doing
stacking art okay who is so selfish
i do this for me it makes me feel good
seven million people on this planet man
like if you keep all this to yourself
sooner or later you're still gonna look
like a junkyard around you
and at some point you're gonna see this
person cave in in depression
and and it's like like where's the
where's where where where do you get the
art out
like you know like i love watches right
most of my
huh so do i yeah most of my watches end
up on somebody else's arm
yeah like i like i have it for a while i
love it for a while and then i'm like
here you have it
yeah and so for me like it needs to get
out
and and um i have a victory in that
yeah i see it on somebody else's arm it
makes me happy yeah
and and so if if i write a book and the
book doesn't get sold
i'm not going to be excited about that
book i need the book in hands of other
people
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five stop
comparing yourself to others with oprah
winfrey what about something that you
feel like you've personally
achieved or overcome is there something
that you are
especially proud of yourself for yeah
i'm especially proud of myself for
not uh living in the world of
comparisons
you know uh years ago when i pulled out
that wagon of fat i was actually
comparing myself to everybody else or
what i thought you're supposed to look
like or what
size you're supposed to be so i now
reach the point where i'm really
okay exactly where i am and
that's you know it's taken me a lifetime
practically to figure that out and
being okay exactly where you are because
preparing is a danger it's so hard
because we are in the world of
insta comparison you know and so the
real spiritual practice
is to like live from within and not
let the world divine who you are but
you do that for yourself that's that's
the hardest work
rule number six fulfill your full
potential with warren buffett
what are the best ways for youth to get
started now in securing their financial
future
for for what to secure their financial
future
for you youth oh well it's not it's not
very complicated
uh it goes back to
getting full use out of your own talents
first
i mean the difference between whether
you're going to be earning x or 2x or 3x
a year
uh 20 years from now uh
is going to be a function of how well
not how much talent you have but how
how well you use the talents you already
have and
so that is the your best financial
future
is your own ability and and
and your uh a capacity to
to use those abilities to their
potential
and they can't take that can be taken
away from you can't they can't even
tax it i mean uh you know most things
if if you want to you know a piece of
real estate if they double the taxes
they double the taxes and that changes
your ownership in the property because
now in effect the taxing authorities own
more of it because they've
got a greater command on the revenue
stream the same thing about
almost any asset you have but
they they don't tax what's in your head
and they don't tax
your ability to start performing when
you when you get to work in the morning
and
finish in the evening uh to to your
potential
one of the things that amazes me is how
people who really do
perform well just sort of jump out at
you once you're running a business when
i got out of school
i thought you know everybody would
behave that way but they don't most
people
sort of go go through life in a
sleepwalk and
and it if you don't you will stand out
so
the big the biggest thing for your
financial future is yourself and rule
number seven the last one before a very
special bonus clip
is care about others with jack ma i
think i'm so
proud that we have so many smart people
in this company
and also so proud in the past 20 years
we make these smart people learn how to
be a human
how to care most smart people want to
win
and we want to make smart people learn
how to
live like a human how to care others
how to do things for the others and when
they learn that
when smart people learn how to care
others
how to care future how to be a human
then the company becomes warm smooth
and soft power otherwise you have a
group of guesters now i've got a very
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get
motivated inspired you have a 35 chance
of following through but when you get
motivated inspired and you create a plan
of action
you have a over 90 chance of following
through and when you share with other
people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood
of following through and so i want that
to be you from this video we don't just
watch videos here believe nation
we do something we take action so i want
to know your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you i don't
know my personality has changed much
since i was five years old
uh i think as i explained to the kids
just a little while ago uh
probably the single most
important aspect of my personality and
as far as determining my success
has been my uh my questioning of
conventional wisdom
my doubting of experts just because
they're experts
and questioning of authority and while
that can be
very very painful in terms of your
relationship with your parents and your
relationship with your teachers
it's enormously useful in life
if you want another amazing video on how
billionaires think
check it out right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there we don't love
this product but we think others will
love it
you know that's not really how it works
if you don't love it don't expect others
will either
your relationship with time is such a
key component
of your life